I hope you didn't pick up Mass Effect
legendary edition for PlayStation in any
Black Friday or Cyber Monday sales as
the game will be a part of December's
PlayStation Plus offering deal Labs user
bilbekun reports that Mass Effect
legendary edition will reportedly be
made available for free December 6 2022
through January 3rd 2023 for all
PlayStation Plus Essentials extra and
premium subscribers the game which only
has a previous gen version is by
extension playable on both PlayStation 4
and Playstation 5. the legendary edition
is a remaster of the original Mass
Effect Trilogy which based on everything
we've seen teased from developer BioWare
regarding the next Mass Effect game will
be all you need to play to prepare
yourself for it sorry Andromeda fans
biomutant and divine knockout are the
two other games rounding out the lineup
with PS4 and PS5 versions available
depending on the console you own
biomutant is developer experiment 101's
post-apocalyptic action game starring a
mammal Warrior of your creation while
Divine knockout is a third person
fighting game featuring evolving
battlefields and multiple game modes
Divine knockout is launching as a part
of PlayStation Plus so it's the one
title you're guaranteed to not already
own if you have an Xbox Microsoft has
confirmed that game pass ultimate and
Xbox Live Gold subscribers will be able
to claim Colt Canyon a top-down shooter
set in a western Wasteland and a bladed
Fury a side-scrolling action game
inspired by Chinese history and
mythology next month Cold Canyon will be
up for grabs all month long while bladed
Fury is free starting December 16th I'm
willing to bet you don't own those
already either if you are a PlayStation
Plus subscriber you might be interested
in the return of PlayStation tournaments
the first of which take place across
Guilty Gear strive NBA 2k23 and FIFA 23
on PS5 you you can register for
tournaments by scrolling to the relevant
game on your home screen and pressing
the down directional button to see a
list of upcoming events some tournaments
might be a part of PlayStation's
win-a-thon which takes place between
December 1st 2022 and January 31st 2023
and is where you can win actual prizes
like a dual sense Edge controller if
you're on PS5 and a PS5 itself if you're
on PS4 full details on everything
PlayStation tournaments at the link in
the description if competitive
multiplayer isn't your thing how about
Cooperative while WB Montreal's Gotham
Knights has offered two-player co-ops
since launch a new update available now
brings its teased four-player heroic
assault to the game this content free to
anyone that owns the game will allow the
full rust of characters to be taken
control of at once in a raid-like
experience between four players players
are tasked with taking down 30 floors of
enemies under the command of staro a fan
favorite DC villain that is also a
mind-controlling starfish before facing
his ultimate puppet the Man-Bat who was
teased in the main game what do you
think of PlayStation Xbox's free
offerings in December are you going to
be jumping into a PlayStation tournament
or into Gotham Knight's new four-player
co-op let us know in the comments we'll
see you here for more Gamespot news
[Music]